acting fema administrator bob fenton
joins us now good morning mr fenton
what are you doing at this point in time
what is fema doing on the ground in
texas right now
right now yeah anthony we have teams and
resources
supporting texas with things like fuel
water meals blankets
and other supply items to support the
population there that's been in the cold
for
almost a week now yeah and temperatures
are expected to drop back into the teens
tonight what has you most worried well
what has me most worried is
making sure that people stay warm texas
has set up a number of
places shelters that they could go
warming stations where people could go
so if you're cold don't stay in your
house go to one of the warming stations
governor abbott has asked president
biden to declare a major
disaster declaration in texas how would
that
impact your ability to provide relief
can you do more with that
yeah so the president declared an
emergency declaration leaning forward
this weekend
that provided me the ability to direct
the federal government resources so all
federal agencies to support
the state of texas in addition to that
it provided me the ability to
reimburse some costs to texas for this
response the major
declaration that the governor is
requesting now
allows me to not only do more things to
repair permanent infrastructure but also
the ability to help individuals so we're
just got that this morning
and we'll be evaluating that and meeting
uh with the president here
to discuss it later on today when you
say help individuals what do you mean
what can you do
well first you know individuals to start
with their insurance that's the
critical way that individuals uh you
know the quickest way
and the best way to make yourself holes
through insurance so we
recommend that if you have insurance to
go through that our individual
assistance program supplements things
like insurance
to either help you uh with uncovered
costs
or other costs to make your home
habitable
in addition to that sba is typically
made available in disasters
and that is another form of assistance
through low interest loans that could
help individuals
has the pandemic in any way limited your
ability to get relief to texas
no the pandemic hasn't eliminated if
anything i've had staff there from the
pandemic as we were
in the process of hoping opening many
community vaccine centers across
many states so i've had staff there
doing working on those in fact
we are still hopeful to set up some
three community vaccine centers next
week
in houston dallas and arlington
so it allowed me to have staff there
already to start responding to this
bob fenton thank you very much for being
with us this morning we really
appreciate it acting fema administrator
thank you